bonjour à tous j'aurais souhaité être
présente parmi vous aujourd'hui je suis
actuellement en métropole pour
participer à la journée de l'assemblée
des départements de france
mais j'ai tenu à vous adresser un
message afin de vous dire
personnellement que si je ne suis pas
présentes parmi vous mon coeur est à vos
côtés
aux côtés des aidants familiaux parce
que vous travaillez aujourd'hui pour
tous nous pouvons en effet être amenés à
devenir des aidants familiaux pour un
nos proches qui perd son autonomie qui
peut tomber malade est en situation de
handicap nos vieux parents
il est donc essentiel que chacun prenne
conscience de l'importance de l'aide
familiale et d'être est dans du rôle que
vous jouez vous êtes aujourd'hui à peu
près 48 milles à exercer ce métier ô
combien essentielle vecteur de
solidarité vecteur de cohésion familiale
alors ce matin cheikh aidant j'ai envie
de vous dire que vous accomplissez au
quotidien un travail essentiel pour la
personne que vous aider bien sûr que
vous accompagnez mais essentiel aussi
pour la réunion et pour la conscience
que la réunion donne sur l'aide à ceux
qui sont les plus défavorisés
votre rôle est de toute évidence est
capital qu'il s'agisse d'une personne
âgée d'une personne porteuse de handicap
elle a le droit de pouvoir vivre chez
elle si elle ne veut pas aller en
établissement ou temps de vous dire que
le maintien à domicile revêt pour nous
au département une dimension politique
stratégique et se maintient à domicile a
été une des priorités d'action dès 2004
quand j'ai accédé à la présidence du
département
nous apportons 20 millions d'euros
annuels pour accompagner l'amélioration
de l'habitat des personnes âgées des
personnes porteuses de handicap en
mettant des pass transport des pass
loisirs nous allons delà de nos
obligations légales jugé nécessaire mais
tous ces dispositifs tous ils ne
représentent rien avec les 100 millions
d'euros si vous n'étiez pas vous
et dans familiaux là pour accomplir les
tâches les plus indispensables si vous
n'aviez pas votre coeur pour donner à
toutes ces personnes nous avons à la
région soutenus bien avant que la
métropole de mettre en place un
dispositif soutenu les aidants familiaux
nous visons une politique de solidarité
qui va dans les deux sens en faveur d
aider comme en faveu résidents que vous
êtes et c'est pour ça que vous savez dès
2012 j'ai mis en place une série de
dispositifs répit repos pour offrir des
temps de respiration de détente
vous êtes ici au village corail c'est un
village qui vous accueille un jardin de
quiétude et qui est à disposition de
tous les miens avec ses cabanes en bois
de goyavier notamment le département a
voulu faire un lieu de repos pour que
vous puissiez vous ressourcer afin
d'assumer un quotidien difficile parfois
je sais que vous faites avec beaucoup de
coeur et beaucoup d'amour
ce qui me permet de terminer avec cette
belle citation de quand je n'ai pas agi
pour avoir du plaisir mais j'ai agi et
j'ai eu du plaisir aujourd'hui je vous
dirai simplement de prendre du plaisir
car cette journée c'est la vôtre
profitez-en pleinement car vous le
méritez vous les aidants familiaux
vous le méritez amplement